all right so here i am in jerusalem they
say the holiest place on earth uh this
is the cradle of civilization right so
right there
is the western wall that is just that
wall where there's
greenery growing out of it that is the
holy site in judaism it's the last
remaining wall of the old temple
on top of it uh that's the dome of the
rock right there
and this is al-aqsa mosque that
everybody's talking about now right
there
you can see it's actually pretty quiet
here i've seen people from every
ethnicity and religion and muslims and
jews and christians and black people and
white people and asian people everybody
all getting along walking next to each
other eating at the same restaurant i
know nobody in the news ever wants you
to see any of that but that's actually
the truth
um unfortunately we can't go to al-aqsa
mosque right now they actually don't
they don't let jews pray up there not
that i was going to go up there to pray
but it's i guess it's closed for
tourists in general right now
but i thought this would be an
interesting place to do a video because
it's a good angle of how these things
are literally
on top of each other these holy things
for people are literally on top of each
other
but there's a lot of coexistence here
it's uh
you know people want everyone to think
everybody's fighting all the time and
yeah this is some prime real estate but
uh there's also some goodness
surrounding it
and
there's some there's call to prayer i
think that's a muslim cult of power
right now
all right more to come